good afternoon everybody and thank you
though I've just chaired a meeting of
the government's Emergency Committee
including ministers from Scotland Wales
and Northern Ireland and it's clear that
coronavirus Cove in nineteen continues
and will continue to spread across the
world and our country over the next few
months we've done what can be done to
contain this disease and this is for
last valuable time but it's now a global
pandemic and the number of cases will
rise sharply indeed the true number of
cases is higher perhaps much higher than
the number of cases we have so far
confirmed with tests and I've got to be
clear we were going to be clear this is
the worst public health crisis for a
generation some people compare it to
seasonal flu alas that is not right
owing to the lack of immunity this
disease is more dangerous and it's going
to spread further and I I must level
with you level with the British public
more families many more families are
going to lose loved ones before their
time and the chief scientific adviser
will set out the best information we
have on that in a moment but as we've
said over the last few weeks we have a
clear plan that we are now working
through and we're now getting on to the
next phase in that plan because this is
now not just an attempt to contain the
disease as far as possible but to delay
its spread and thereby minimize the
suffering if we delay the peak even by a
few weeks then our NHS will be in a
stronger state as the weather improves
and fewer people suffer from normal
respiratory diseases more beds are
available and we'll have more time for
medical research we can also act to
stretch the peak of the disease over a
longer period so that our society is
better able to cope the chief medical
officer will set out
lines of defense we have to deploy these
at the right time to maximize their
effect the most important task will be
to protect our elderly and most
vulnerable people during the peak weeks
when there is the maximum risk of
exposure to the disease and when the NHS
will be under the most pressure so the
most dangerous period is not now but
some weeks away depending on how fast it
spreads today therefore we're moving
forward with our plan from tomorrow if
you have coronavirus symptoms however
mild either a new continuous cough or a
high temperature then you should stay at
home for at least seven days to protect
others and health slow the spread of the
disease we advise all those over 70 with
serious medical conditions against going
on cruises and we advise against
international school trips at some point
in the next few weeks we are likely to
go further and if someone in a household
has those symptoms we will be asking
everyone in that household to stay at
home we're not introducing this measure
yet for reasons Sir Patrick will explain
but I want a signal now that this is
coming down the track we are considering
the question of banning major public
events such as sporting fixtures and the
scientific advices we've said over the
last couple of weeks is that this
banning such events will have little
effect on the spread but there is also
the issue of the burden that such events
can place on public services so we're
discussing these issues with colleagues
in all parts of the United Kingdom and
we'll have more to say shortly about the
timing of further action in that respect
at all stages we have been guided
by the science and we will do the right
thing at the right time
we are not repeat not closing schools
now the scientific advice is that this
could do more harm than good
at this time but of course we're keeping
this under review and this again may
change as the disease spreads schools
should only close if they are
specifically advised to do so and that
remains our advice there is no escaping
the reality that these measures will
cause severe disruption across our
country for many months the best
scientific advice is that this will help
us slow the disease and save lives there
will be detailed information available
on the NHS website and from one one one
online but I want to stress something
that's very important in the wake of
what we're saying this afternoon I urge
people who think in view of what we're
saying about their potential symptoms
that they should stay at home I urge
them not to call one one one but to use
the internet for information if they can
I also want at this stage to speak
directly to older people because this
disease is particularly dangerous for
you for older people even though the
vast majority of older people will
experience a mild to moderate illness I
know that many people will be very
worried and I think we should all be
thinking about our elderly relatives
there are more vulnerable members of our
family our neighbours and everything we
can do to protect them over the next few
months we're going to need to mobilize
millions of people to help and support
each other and I just want you to know
that the government will do all we can
to help you and your family during this
period we're not just going to be as you
saw yesterday supporting the economy
during this period we will be providing
money and many other forms of support
and helping communities to support each
other and as we've done over the last
few weeks we will continue to provide as
soon as we have it as much clear
scientific and medical information as we
can so I'd like to end by repeating the
two important messages with which you
will become familiar it is still vital
that's more vital than ever that we
remember to wash our hands and lastly of
course even if things seem tough now
just to remember that we will get
through this this country will get
through this epidemic just as it has got
through many tougher experiences before
if we look out for each other and commit
wholeheartedly to a full national effort